the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video well my
friends the day is finally here as you
can see hbo has officially released
their first full trailer for their new
game of thrones series house of the
dragon and i must say everything looks
like it will be amazing in this first
season after looking at all the
different sets the different locations
the wardrobe the armor the battles and
even the dragons the first season of
house of the dragon looks almost as
incredible as the final season of game
of thrones hbo and everyone else
involved obviously did an amazing job on
this show it was definitely worth
waiting for as you can see we are now
entering a new era in the game of
thrones saga ladies and gentlemen house
of the dragon is here and ready to leave
their mark now let's get into the video
the first season of house of the dragon
will mostly focus on the line of
succession they made that very obvious
with all of the different lines of
dialogue in this trailer for those of
you who don't know king viserys
targaryen will have to decide who will
run the seven kingdoms after he is gone
when house of the dragon begins viserys
will be left without any sons of his own
unfortunately his first wife will die
before he is given an heir this means he
will have to decide if he will leave the
iron throne for his brother daemon or
his daughter rhaenyra now although
viserys does love his brother daemon he
doesn't want him to become the king now
when it comes to rhaenyra the issue is
women have no rights to the iron throne
this was established during the reign of
viserys targaryen's father king jiharis
someone we will meet in the very first
episode when they have the great council
of 101ac at harrenhal during the great
council viserys targaryen is elected as
the next king of the seven kingdoms
however it was also decided that no
woman can sit on the iron throne we will
see viserys go against this law when he
names his daughter rhaenyra as his heir
we hear serato help set this in motion
when he says it's urgent that viserys
decides what he will do with the matter
of succession you see serato hates the
king's brother daemon he's worried that
daemon will sit on the iron throne after
viserys is gone he will urge viserys to
name his daughter as his heir which he
will eventually do since he doesn't have
any sons when viserys makes rhaenyra his
heir most of the lords and ladies will
arrive at the red keep to swear they're
fealty now since this is a song of ice
and fire we know this won't end with a
happily ever after you see viserys
doesn't stay unmarried for very long he
eventually gets remarried to allison
hightower the daughter of serato
hightower who is his hand of the king
now what makes this really interesting
is the fact that viserys's new wife
alicent was great friends with his
daughter rhaenyra we will see their
great relationship at the beginning of
the show however their friendship will
eventually go up in flames it's not long
before viserys and alicent begin having
kids of their own
they end up having several sons named
aegon aemond and daron now although
viserys will have sons he doesn't make
any changes to his line of succession
rhaenyra remains as his heir for the
iron throne that is until viserys dies
now you would think rhaenyra would just
sit on the iron throne after her father
died but the only issue is she wasn't in
king's landing when that happened she
was on dragonstone getting ready to have
a daughter of her own we hear rhaenys
targaryen tell her husband lord coreless
valerion that rhaenyra's claim will be
challenged not only because she's a
woman but because viserys now has sons
who most believe should be next in line
now when king viserys dies alison and
her father serado have the city on
lockdown they begin making arrangements
to have alison and viserys's son aegon
sit on the iron throne before rhaenyra
even learns what happened as a matter of
fact viserys is dead for over a week
before rhaenyra finds out her father
died by then allison and serato have
already set things in motion for them to
keep the city under their control this
absolutely destroys what was once a
great relationship between rhaenyra and
alicent this will obviously lead to an
all-out war now this is the main story
which will be the backbone of house of
the dragon but let's have a look at some
of the other scenes from the trailer one
thing that really sets this trailer
apart from the other teasers is the
amount of dragons we finally see
in one shot we see a dragon flying near
the dragon pit of king's landing this
was back when it was still a massive
dome castle sitting on rainey's hill
this is actually where we will see
viserys and allison's son aegon be
crowned as the new king before rhaenyra
even knows her father has died we also
see many great shots of the different
tournaments during the first season
as we've already seen in some of the
official photos we will see daemon and
sir kristin cole fight during one of
these events in fact daemon will lose to
sir kristen cole on two different
occasions for those of you who don't
know sir kristin cole will become the
lore commander of the kingsguard after
sir harold westerling now another thing
we see is rhaenyra and lanor velaryon
walking along the beach most likely on
dragonstone lanor velaryon is the son of
lord corliss velaryon and rainey's
targaryen rhaenyra and lenore will have
three sons during their marriage however
it is rumored that these three sons were
actually fathered by another man
we might even find out that this
marriage was most likely for show and to
strengthen the alliance between houses
targaryen and velaryon we also see
several shots of daemon leading the city
watch of king's landing this will be
when daemon is the lore commander of the
city watch he's actually the one who
gives them their gold cloaks something
they will be known for from here on out
one thing daemon loves to do while lore
commander the city watch is instill some
law and order among the small folk this
isn't the only thing we will see daemon
do however in the first season he will
be a very busy man along with his friend
lorcorlis velaryon daemon and lore
corliss will start a war of their own
when they fight a series of land and
naval battles on the stepstones after
viserys refuses the name daemon as his
heir he decides to build a kingdom of
his own so him and corliss begin
striking these small islands for
ultimate control daemon will eventually
be named as the king of the stepstones
and the narrow sea however he won't hold
this for very long another character we
meet in the trailer is aemon one eye
targaryen the son of viserys in alicent
as you can see he wears an eye patch
over one of his eyes thanks to
rhaenyra's son you see aemon and his
siblings became bitter rivals of
rhaenyra's sons for stealing their
birthright another thing that will
happen is king viserys will suggest that
amon who out of all his siblings was the
only one who didn't have a dragon of his
own could claim a dragon egg or
hatchling on dragonstone for his own if
he was bold enough annoyed by his father
aemon resolved to claim veigar the
oldest of the dragons who had recently
become riderless with the death of lana
velaryon now aemon who knew that his
father would not allow him near the
dragon went to make this ride in secret
only aemon was caught by his
three-year-old nephew joffrey who is one
of rhaenyra's sons now in order to keep
him quiet aemon slapped and threatened
the younger boy before shoving him into
some of the dragon droppings after
joffrey began to yell amon climbed on
the top of vegard's back the dragon
broke free of her chains and aemon flew
in circles before landing joffrey
however had alarmed his older brothers
jacarys and lucari's velaryon the four
boys fought with wooden swords that is
until aemon called his nephew strong's
insisting that they were bastards
jacarys who was old enough to understand
the insult attacked aemond again now
when amon gains the upper hand and
begins to beat jacary savagely lucario's
drew his dagger and slashed at aemon's
face removing his right eye after this
incident alison demanded that luceries
lose an eye as well which king viserys
refused while rhaenyra demanded that
aemon was also to be held accountable
since he was suggesting they were
bastards and therefore rhaenyra was
guilty of high treason by sleeping with
sir harwin strong this was a big issue
as you can see this incident causes a
lot of issues among rhaenyra and alison
further dividing their friendship the
first season will have a lot of drama
dividing house targaryen right down the
middle leading to enough fire and blood
that will leave this once large house
and its dragons and shambles i would get
ready ladies and gentlemen because house
of the dragon is finally here if any of
you want to know all of the little
details regarding these events i will
link some of my other videos down below
i don't want to ruin everything in this
video because i'm sure some of you don't
want to know everything just yet but for
those of you who do there are more
videos down below where i go over
everything that's written in george rr
martin's fire and blood
like i said at the beginning of this
video i'm very happy with how everything
looks and feels with what i've seen so
far all of the actors look great in
their roles in the sets in the different
locations and the different wardrobes
and armor and the damn dragons look
amazing i cannot wait for the show to
finally air i hope all of you come back
here when i make all of my videos during
the season i have so many more heading
your way as always i want to thank
everyone for watching this video i hope
all of you have a great day i will see
you again very soon
bye
so
[Music]
so
so
you